bijoux déco et petits lutins 76 artisans
en intérieur le marché de noël de
montigny le bretonneux accueilli nouveau
venu est habitué au détour des stands
pour ses 20 ans à la ferme du manège
pour dany et ses doudous tricoté main
c'est la deuxième fois c'est très
agréable que deux ans seraient souriant
majorité en tous cas pour sonia casano
et ses bougies colorées et vernis
c'était une première on est ravi parce
que ça a l'air de plaire pas mal c'est
vrai qu'on n'est le en a la chance en
est le seul stand qui vend des bougies
et noël basse ville et produits
commencer
non
les 53 exposants des produits
alimentaires sont en extérieur les
champenois offre une petite coupe à
leurs voisins du stand de fruits frais
déshydraté présent pour la quatrième
année la convivialité avant tout
d'amener vous déshydrater
c'est trop bon
c'est bon
je saurais pas trop les fraises oui mais
sinon je serais pas où les mettre et
quand on les mangeait en fait ça mais
non c'est bien ça permet de découvrir
des nouveaux et nouvelles choses c'est
vrai que c'est sympa parce que c'est ça
c'est artisanal on a fait les achats
pour noël rien que pour ça et goûter et
on a pris en photo avec le père noël
car sans la traditionnelle photo du père
noël point de marché digne de ce nom